à chaque polémique son hashtag
aujourd'hui c'est mélanie qui est la
cible de nombreux internautes pour avoir
fièrement afficher ses poils sur twitter
en effet la jeune femme ouvertement
féministe a décidé d'assumer sa pilosité
naturel en refusant le diktat de
l'épilation imposées aux femmes une
photo pour laquelle elle n'imaginait
certainement pas devenir une cible c'est
un conte anti féministe qui s'est
emparée de cette publication avant que
des centaines d'internautes décide de
suivre le pas et de s'en prendre à elle
à coups d'insultés de moqueries un
acharnement que certains ont décidé de
contrer ans l'enfant le hashtag je garde
mes poils et en y joignant des photos de
leurs corps n'ont épiler alors le
mouvement je garde mes poils j'aime ou
j'aime pas
votons pas question qu'un copain on nous
parle des sujets qui ont le plus
commenté aujourd'hui sur les réseaux est
partout donc ça c'était le sujet numéro
4 oui valérie bella leurs soutiens
évidemment à mélanie évidemment il n'y a
eu aucune cause qui fait qui mérite que
l'on se fasse harcelée qu'on se fasse
emmerder est sûr et je constate encore
une fois que le corps des femmes pose un
souci et quand on le montre dans sa
crudité et on va on emmerde les gens
voient la gérabilité l'horizon saoudien
talus au sublime
j'espérais que voilà mais en revanche je
ne pense pas que le combat des féminines
2.0 des fémurs aimé qu'on appelle les
néo féministe passe par le poil pardon
canton 70 les femmes brûlé leur soutien
gorge ça avait un sens là ça n'a pas de
sens pour moi il ya d'autres combats à
mener
la parité les violences faites aux
femmes l'égalité salariale et free à
d'autres combats
allez rêver
la la c'est un truc sur twitter qui a
émergé et artix alors qu'eddy alors
chaque année on our bassine avec cette
histoire de poils donc chaque année on
essaie de relancer cette mode qui ne
prouve chez se prend sa part robert
l'avait fait sur le tapis rouge mais
julia roberts robert joly evans known as
aussi oui elles ont tout essayé de le
faire mais malheureusement tous repartis
avec leurs rasoirs elles sont en train
de se raser l'autre ça ne prend pas le
problème c'est que là c'est dépassé
c'est à dire qu'on essaie de défendre
une cause le féminisme avec quelque
chose de deux de trop provocateur pour
que ce soit crédible et qu'on puisse
l'entendre
après si c'est une raison médicale je
peux le comprendre voile c'est là sur le
corps et l'âme à limoges
ça promet c'est vrai que si c'est au
niveau médical je reviens mais c'est
juste pour le féminisme
ça défend pas la meilleure 2 kelly et
valérie ont du talent mais vous ne
l'exploité jamais seul
c'est un symbole
mais quand ça les arrange finir parce
qu'avec le tissu de conneries vous avez
dit que je trouve formidable c'est que
toujours un homme explique annie
[Applaudissements]
s'abattront moi et c'est bon la gym qui
veut parler essayer d'attraper quelque
chose elle va taper la queue du mickey
mais c'est oui on n'est pas méprise les
femmes heureusement mécano life agréable
a dit oui mais moi une femme non et je
vais écouter c'est le mouvement
d'aujourd'hui de l'émancipation sociale
a ouï dire non aux normes c'est être soi
même si elles ont envie si elles se
sentent belles comme ça et ça a dû lui
je ne les juge et pas la dérive jugé par
dit qu'aujourd'hui on rame en préambule
est ce ke tu m'a entendu jugé ces femmes
en préambule
j'ai apporté mon soutien cette jeune
femme qui en préambule j'ai dit que les
femmes faisait ce qu'elle voulait sur le
récent changement lorsqu'on utilise des
choses là ni l'éthique à la marche pas
qui me semble hyper alors on va voir ses
remparts ses téléspectateurs s'il vous
plaît à regarder a tout dit j'aime 23%
et wissant ils sont plutôt d'accord avec
valérie bénaïm on va passer au troisième
volet c'est dommage mais alors que jamie
dont jean louis marie parce que moi j'ai
une part de féminisme en moi s'est
dressée près mais pour la finition
ça va pas parler quoi ce jeu vos cheveux
l'égalité des salaires l'oeuf à la fin
du machisme dans certains secteurs de la
politique le sport par les cheveux mais
je sortais avec une fille je manque un
peu de respect avec une fille qui était
une ancienne travailleuse du bois de
boulogne et qui souffraient
malheureusement deux fils autiste est
excessive entre les amoureux d'elles
s'était battu terme révèle évidemment
pas mal rigolé pas de rigoler pas si
vous pouvez laisser le fini voilà elle
met du poil en souffraient de pilosité
excessive entre les seins ça descendait
comme ça
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]